ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
ciao ciao ciao ciao
siamo Favij e Marco merrino Incredibile
siamo tornati nello studio Magico come
vedete si evolve sempre di più adesso
abbiamo due piante abbiamo uno sfondo
animato e abbiamo soprattutto la feature
migliore che è Marco e adesso stiamo per
fare una televisione di Jolly Marco
glielo spiego perché non lo sa è
un'intelligenza artificiale dove tu
scrivi una frase e questi intelligenza
artificiale ti genera delle immagini
quattro della frase che hai scritto
quindi io posso scrivere uomo con barba
e occhiali calcio una bottiglietta
proviamo Però proviamo Assen
Waterboys Vediamo Ah ah ah ah
abbiamo scritto una frase a testa da
dire all'avversario e ognuno di noi deve
indovinare che cos'altro ha scritto
dalle immagini Partito Marcos Vediamo se
indovino Fai partire la mia prima
Giampiero
[Musica]
è un po' il contrario allora Io ti
consiglierei forse la seconda quella più
prendi la seconda Allora
è terrificante Allora cani
incazzatissimo sembra un Pokémon cane
alato
No questo è il contrario di quello che
ho voluto Esatto Ok un gigantesco pollo
attacca un cane piccolo Bravo bravo
maldog Fighting a Gigantic chic adesso
devi indovinare la mia Speriamo che la
faccia bene Noi non l'abbiamo viste
prima quindi non so cosa stia tirando
fuori vediamo ok Hehehe Mamma mia hai
cercato camion plummer exciting from a
pipe ho cercato Eh volevi cercare Super
Mario che cerca di infilarsi in un tubo
verde quindi ho scritto idraulico con
salopette Entra in YouTube non è male ma
la seconda è bellissima Ecco non si che
cos'è
è il nuovo album Nirvana
Comunque l'ultima è veramente Super
Mario ragazzi
Next di Marco
Con che faccia Me lo sta dicendo poi
quello è il contrario di quello che ho
voluto statua dell'isola di Pasqua tiene
una persona limona no osserva No la
bocca sempre parla No Pensa a me urla No
a me a me statua nell'isola di Pasqua
grossa Come si diventa grosso mangia
mangia salta l'episodio di Pasqua mangia
una bomba cioè il primo è veramente
primo di incontrare
questo sto vedendo ma poi con che faccia
ti prego Ma cos'è dai Eh per caso dai
perché solo la politica italiana che non
accetta la coppia lesbica di Peppa Pig
no però Wow ci stava quasi dai non è
italiana non è italiana la politica Ah
coso Uh Maiden ho messo il presidente
degli Stati Uniti ti guarda un cartone
sugli sui maiali che dovrebbe essere
Peppa Pig però non posso uscire per
partite mi piacerebbe che nel mondo lo
guardavo un maialino Eh l'ha fatta bene
Questa l'ha fatta i Pazzesco questa era
pazzesca ragazzi Qua ho voluto
utilizzare un personaggio famoso della
cultura Pop
funko Pop questa cultura è molto Joker
si trucca da KIKO più generale c'è Joker
giocattolo va a comprare dei trucchi in
un negozio Beauty
Joker
lui è palesemente Giovanni in Aldo
Giovanni e Giacomo
Ok allora questo è presente il Questo è
quello che io ti ho detto un giorno no
non come no no bro la mia fantasia è
questa cioè da una finestra un uomo si
vede uno tsunami di pulcini che gli
arriva addosso molto simile però non la
mia fantasia che ho da bambino Io
pensavo dello raccontato a lui cazzate
ti giuro però ho scritto Tsunami di però
non di pulcini di di papere di gomma
che colpisce un grattacielo Abbiamo
avuto lo stesso pensiero ma non esiste
sarà una prerogativa di chi fa i video
avere questo avere
pulcini bellissimo bellissimo Comunque
sì questa era fatta molto bene ma prima
di continuare con le immagini di oggi
[Musica]
via con lo sponsor di oggi è lo sponsor
di oggi ragazzi è il laptop che mi
salverà la vita e che mi serviva per i
prossimi video perché mentre giro per il
mondo dovrò renderizzarli in qualche
modo ed è il Vector GP 76 della MSI
questo bolide di laptop è più forte
quasi del mio computer fisso ha delle
caratteristiche mostruose e grazie alla
potente gpu Nvidia della serie 3000 è
possibile giocare comodamente ai giochi
Tripla anche sul letto top Veramente
anche dedicare con estrema facilità per
questo potrà evitare in giro per il
mondo cercherò di ehm di dirvi tutte le
caratteristiche appunto del Vector GP 76
prima che lui finisca di renderizzare e
non so se ce la farò tre due uno Let's
go CPU fino a core che è un processore
della Madonna visto che rendering è già
a un quarto e io sono appena inizio
scheda grafica Nvidia GeForce rtx fino a
3.080 ti hai dopodiché abbiamo il
sistema di raffreddamento Cooler Boost
ahve la pronuncia giusta l'hard disk SSD
di quarta generazione ce l'ho fatta
abbiamo la magica Keyboard che potete
vedere dal fatto che si illuminano tutti
i tasti Ho vinto io lui ha finito adesso
io ho finito adesso quindi ho vinto io
di un tipo un secondo che vale
Se volete eccellere in questi campi
Questa è la macchina giusta e noi
torniamo ad eccellere con l'intelligenza
artificiale bello bello ci siamo
Ovviamente la prima il contrario
incredibile Allora tu scrivi il
contrario delle cose che te le fa'
giusta
allora semplicemente il mondo che si
apre e dentro di cioccolato
questa ci sta questo è un nfte
[Musica]
non Santo Iddio Allora Babbo Natale sì
che spara e io sto solo raccontando
quello che sto vedendo adesso
un cazzo di arcobaleno a Natale a me
piace molto la terza per il bambino
rimane
sciolto Babbo Natale decidi di regalare
l'arcobaleno ai bambini buoni per
iniziare era Babbo Natale eh caga sotto
l'albero di Natale arcobaleni mentre
qualcuno lo sta filmando però cagare non
veniva fuori quindi vomitare ho scritto
ma non Stavo vomitando
puoi mettere la terza
cos'è ragazze pittore
dipinge bendato
Questa è maledettamente il contrario
come sempre pittore pelato dipinge
bendato Allora in realtà era Blind Man
Riley bed and breakfast
Peccato perché volevo almeno un disegno
oh oh Sicuramente è un uomo che fa
un'azione o un altro uomo
youtuber alto
slappa il proprio basso su uno youtuber
con le cuffie
che è di base dovrebbe essere dei bifavo
forte mi dà un basso in testa questo non
sono io e non è devi fare fuori puoi
dire che voglio fare l'amore con lui e
penso che vedrà Questo video è sposata
Si è sposato ieri [ __ ]
Cleopatra Allora
ho cercato assassino pentito in paradiso
eh eh si sente quindi anche secondo
momento e si tromba Questa è la faccia
di un pentito
[Musica]
mamma che guida una macchina quale
macchina la Ferrari Sì con non in questa
cambio metti l'altra
con i piedi Sì ho messo scimmia guida
una Ferrari con i piedi però questa non
è una scimmia e le altre sono scimmie ma
non stanno guidando con i piedi tranne
quella che i piedi fuori dalla macchina
no ma ti prego lascia questa Lascia
quella
Ma che facce sono mamma tieni in braccio
un bambino the boss Beautiful mom
carring the uglyest baby la mamma più
bella del mondo è Non penso ci siano
dubbi che tiene il bambino brutto brutto
bambino e penso che qua ci siano dei
dubbi
Zlatan Ibrahimovic dalla mano a Gerry
Scotti no Tutti per uno uno per tutti
arabo No no siamo io e te che ci teniamo
mano per mano Chi sei tu e chi sono io
non ci somiglia ancora a fare la stessa
espressione
[Musica]
Abbiamo apprezzato il tentativo
Bellissimo Bello quindi ragazzi Questo
era dalle due con Marco
che è venuta benissimo del presidente
biden ma anche Tsunami di papera
perfetta ragazzi Spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto Fatemi sapere delle idee da
scrivere per la prossima volta che
facciamo una puntata del genere Visto
che ormai lo standardizziamo un Format
Troppo bello troppo divertente Ci sono
tante cacate quindi scrivete qua sotto
che cosa potremmo scrivere nella
prossima non valgono robe tipo offensive
violente perché non le prendo Ok il giro
nei prossimi episodio iscrivetevi al
canale anche voi Marco e un bacino a
tutti ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
ciao ciao ciao